cloué à sa chaise roulante
ivo cournoyer entretient depuis des mois
le même rêve décider lui même de la
façon et de la date à laquelle il va
partir la dignité
moi j'ai toujours répété son geste au
roster la dignité dignité c'est le mot
qui revient toujours dans la bouche de
celui que nous suivons depuis mars 2017
il sait qu'il est condamné depuis qu'il
a reçu en 2016
un diagnostic de sclérose latérale
amyotrophique aussi appelée maladie de
lou gehrig
il songe tout de suite à l'aide médicale
à mourir c'est moi qui va décider qu'un
mamouri sommes en jeu de sylvain décidé
mais moi dans ma taille l'aide à mourir
je pensais que ça fascine on lui
explique d'abord qu'il n'est pas
admissible parce qu'il n'est pas à moins
d'un an de son décès il décide alors de
porter son message dans les médias il
s'agit de chaplin m
que nos politiciens même s'il n'est pas
en fin de vie il veut absolument l'aide
médicale à mourir si rapidement peace
paix est alors on vous dit pourquoi
je mouille high five à ma faille de la
faillite celle 2 me ce sera mon cadeau
sa présence dans les médias lui vaut une
invitation à l'assemblée nationale
actuellement la loi comme un état dire
est enfin une vie il faut de choix
de la fjfnb mais il ne peut obtenir les
médicale à mourir en juin parce qu'il
lui reste plus d'un an à vivre
en attendant la mort il décide de
profiter de la vie
en nous il effectue un troisième saut en
parachute
mais la maladie elle progresse en force
pour l'inspiration l'expiration fin
septembre sa respiration est atteinte il
entre dans la phase la plus cruelle de
la maladie on va travailler fort pour un
voyage en amoureux octobre arrive son
déclin s'accélère
yvan cournoyer formule la demande à ce
médecin
moi je t'ai dit gemma partie de gens en
vie 2018 je dire est une possibilité de
devancer elle m'a dit oui
elle accepte de lui prodiguer les
médicale à mourir le 11 novembre yves on
est content d'accélérer les choses pour
dit il
épargnés c'est parce que c'est une
opportunité qui à qui
bien sûr ce que tout le monde autour on
a tout vu de la terne mais
10 novembre la veille du décès prévus
les cathéters qui vont acheminer les
produits mortels sont en place yvon fait
face à la mort sans broncher
il pense avoir contribué à changer les
choses avec ses sorties sur la nécessité
d'élargir l'accès à l'aide médicale a
mûri roja est éligible jeunes engagés
ça va faire demain leur novembre 2007 à
la veille de sa mort les visites se
succèdent au domicile d'yves ans et j'en
vois un bulletin de venir me voir ni
musée qui même puis moi de mon côté la
manche aux factions ces drames à l'aise
je m'arrête pas calculer les ans tout le
temps mais j'ai ainsi que pour ses
proches le 2 et débute déjà mais yvon et
sa conjointe ont gardé le sourire
jusqu'à la fin un pied de nez à la
fatalité
difficile de trouver les bons mots quand
on serre la main de quelqu'un qu'on ne
reverra jamais
[Musique]
ils vont cournoyer est mort paisiblement
samedi entourés d'une vingtaine de
personnes allongées aux côtés de sa
conjointe ici david gentili radio-canada
saint-ignace-de-loyola